it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
expert Ashley Bellman joins us right now
so let's get right to it so you have
something that can help with spills and
drops yes this is drop stop it is
National distracted drivers awareness
month and this is the yes okay the only
proven thing that will help stop you
from being distracted this was the
number one thing to come out of Shark
Tank you hook this device over the seat
belt catch it's going to stop your keys
your French fries your phone from
falling in that bottomless black hole
pit in between the seat and the center
console it comes with two so you can put
one in the driver's seat one on the
passenger seat Universal fit this is so
effective all of the LAPD police cars
have this in their rooms yes and it's
just so unfortunate when you have to
reach down most accidents happen when
you take your eyes off the wheel for
three seconds or less the deal is great
15.99 today it is 36 off and this always
goes fast go so run to CBS deals if you
drop those keys some change anything
it's wild come up with those gnarled
fingers cut by hand yeah don't want to
do that that's a great deal okay so this
is something that's going to help
drivers feel safer feel safer and
independent this is Jump smart so this
is a 10 in one car jump smarter jump
starter it is amazing so this is so it's
a jump smarter though it is a jump
smarter you're right you're right all
right thank you for that it's so easy
you hook black to black red to red and
it takes the question out of jump
starting your vehicle so you cannot get
shocked the most stressful time when
you're trying to figure out Plus versus
minus where does it go I simply wouldn't
do it and I'd have to call my dad or my
husband and now I can drive
independently and not feel like I need
to call someone for help plus it has a
flashlight plus it has a portable
charger also this charged one time will
will jump start your car 38 times so a
flashlight multiple settings then also a
compass compass thermometer you name it
multiple Outlets to charge your phone
this is the one thing you need and it's
so the driver impact it's so good it's
so cool and I love all the different
colors 109.99 today is the deal and it's
31 off get this for everyone you know
that drives it so those days of lugging
around those long cables having to back
two cars together front words and
figuring out what's going on that to me
that's just call roadside assistance I
don't even know what that is this is
going to help a ton of people definitely
all right so pickleball okay so I don't
know if you've heard but pickleball is
the fastest
sport in the country so it is time to
pick up your paddles and no better place
to start than Rockne they are bringing
uh Courtside aesthetic back these are
beautiful quality uh paddles the deals
start at 89.99 today now there's
something for everyone if you are a more
seasoned player that is the one for you
that is the carbon X that's the black
one if you are are just a beginner start
with one of the ones with the white
backgrounds great options for you they
are so Innovative there's a honeycomb
Center that's going to help you get a
great hit every single time lightweight
lightweight beautiful go to cbsdeals.com
there's all these really beautiful
accessories that come with them as well
I don't know about you but I don't play
this makes me want to play no doubt
because you're going to look good
playing because you got to look the part
yes you look good feel good feel good
play good exactly 50 off there's all
different bundles so get the one that's
perfect for you that's Rockne all right
this is okay the rush charge this is the
rush charge Comet so as you know we all
have trillions of devices that all need
to be charged this is so lightweight
it's a three in one portable charger so
it is the only thing you need throw it
in your bag comes in different colors
charge your headphones charge your phone
charge your iPad
that's a game controller which by the
way I didn't know that you charged these
days that's how ungaming I
yes 48.99 30 off today this is great I
love this for watching my shows while
I'm commuting into this city it's
awesome different colors I have one in
everything there's a phone a tablet and
then some yes and pass through
technology too so I could charge the
charger while I'm charging my devices as
well Ah that's fire okay it's a great
deal too such a great deal 30 off today
under fifty dollars I'm telling you get
one for you get one for your best friend
you're the best I appreciate you all
right of course we partnered with all
these companies to get these deals to
buy anything that you saw in more scan
the QR code on your screen right now or
head over to cbsdeals.com to start
shopping now